he's a long long way from home and she's
a long way of returning to the place
that she's called home for most of her
life foreigners yes but drawn to kiev by
a common heritage I feel that Ukraine is
my my homeland South London girl Holly
Ollis oscar has been in ukraine for
months she actually came as an
international election observer but when
the maid and movement began she found
she just couldn't leave as a member of
the Ukrainian diaspora I think that it
really helps for the public the people
of Ukraine to really see us here see our
presence here supporting them and just
for them to know that we are here and
that we're here for them that urge to
bear witness is common amongst Ukrainian
descendants who found themselves
immersed in the movement for change what
should have ended after Christmas break
with his relatives has stretched into a
political marathon for New Zealand adem
gin doroshenko his family ruled Ukraine
several times over the last century and
he feels he owes the people here his
time I'm Ukrainian bye bye first
generation my parents Ukrainian and it's
very important for me for myself and for
my heritage to be here to support the my
fellow brothers and sisters in Ukraine
like lalia damn chooses to stay not in a
hotel but in a shared space right in the
heart of Maidan the square that gave its
name to the political movement of the
protesters now transformed into a
veritable village food donations
handouts communal effort keep things
going and there's no special treatment
for visitors it's like a family that
everybody is helps each other we all
support each other and there's this
feeling of closeness united by the the
need to be free to have freedom to be in
a different group democratic country as
we have a new zealand or England or
Australia and it's very important that
we understand that these people need
help they've given up jobs left behind
family and friends and yet neither is in
any rush
to leave they've witnessed up close what
most of us have only learnt about from
afar and they want to stay to make sure
things really do change Michelle
Clifford Sky News Kiev